the internet repository of all human
knowledge and videos of goats singing
Taylor Swift songs
[Music]
[Applause]
come on the Internet is an incredible
place and tonight we need to talk about
an issue that is impacting it net
neutrality if that certain rings a bell
we actually talked about it in our fifth
ever episode three years ago a piece
that got a weird amount of attention
last week tonight with John Oliver has
languished in relative obscurity since
its debut in April but this week an
Oliver diatribe about net neutrality
went viral hi
you lady language and relatives
Ozzie life relative obscurity when a
village or tea is my middle name but
incredibly being nagged by WGBH Boston
was not the weirdest bit of attention of
that segment attracted that without a
doubt would be this all right it's
comedian John Oliver in New York is it a
big piece on net neutrality and the FCC
and he directed everybody to go to the
FCC website and leave like hateful
comments and it turns out it totally
worked
the FCC's website crack you get a job I
was doing it what people did it yeah I
just merely pointed out a problem now
yeah
I will event starting a quintessentially
British excuse you cannot possibly hold
me responsible for the masses decide to
make a fuss about now run along
scallywag I said good day to you good
day sir now the reason for our segment
three years ago was that the future of
net neutrality was in question and to
their credit the FCC took steps to
safeguard ease and if you're wondering
why I'm even bringing up a problem that
was seemingly solved this is why the
Trump administration today announcing
plans to rollback Obama era net
neutrality rules unequal access of
course it seems that the Trump era will
basically controls the everything that
happened on Obama's watch I genuinely
would not be surprised if one night
Trump went on TV just to tell us that he
personally killed every turkey Obama
ever pardons
but the point is though once again net
neutrality is in trouble and if you need
a refresher on what it involves
please let me start of the 2007 viral
smash video Chocolate Rain explain it to
you in 30 seconds net neutrality is the
idea that your pipe to the internet
whether that is your cable internet
connection your LTE wireless internet
connection however you are receiving
information via the internet that
pipeline to the Internet is not allowed
to arbitrarily pick favorites in terms
of the content that you consume for
example if you like to use Google search
and your roommate likes to use being
searched your internet service provider
can't say well being is paying us a lot
of money so we're going to slow down
Google and Yahoo and their other search
engine competitors to make being load
fast he's right
although that's obviously just a
hypothetical there's clearly no such
search engine as Bing or maybe there is
I don't know that there's really only
one way to find out and that's by
googling it and that kind of the point
but but net neutrality is about more
than just theme and it's hot it is the
principle that Internet service
providers or ISPs like these guys should
not be able to engage in any sort of
that limits or manipulates the
choices you make online it also helps
ensure a level playing field so that big
companies cannot undermine small
companies before they can take off and
without it ancestry.com could easily
crush my new site just tell me if I'm
related to a Nazi com
it's like ancestry.com except you get to
skip all the net neutrality is
objectively boring and that used to work
to ISPs advantage but more people know
what it is now which is why some
companies have started putting out
statements trumpeting their support for
a free and open Internet that Verizon
even created a video to calm any
concerns that you might have hey what's
up everybody Jeremy here with Craig
silliman who is our general counsel and
leads our public policy group let's jump
right into it is the FCC going to kill
what we know as the open Internet rules
or net neutrality the FCC is not talking
about killing the net neutrality rules
in fact not we nor any other ISP or
asking them to kill the open Internet
rules all they're doing is looking to
put the open Internet rules in an
enforceable way on a different legal
footing now that sounds reasonable and
why wouldn't you trust the commitment to
open access of a man sitting at a table
literally blocking an entire hallway but
but well but while a different legal
footing sounds pretty benign it is not
and it is also worth understanding how
net neutrality landed on its current
legal footing because it happens to
directly involve the Rison so let me
explain and unfortunately to do that I
have to introduce you to two terms even
more boring than net neutrality
specifically title 1 and title 2 of the
Communications Act of 1934 the
equivalent of chasing an ambien with a
shot of chloroform but here is very
broadly what happened back in 2010 the
FCC wrote net neutrality rules governing
ISPs which at the time were regulated
under the less strict title one and the
companies found those net neutrality
rules inconvenient in fact the Rison
successfully sumed the FCC arguing that
it didn't have enough authority to
enforce those rules and the court ruled
that if the FCC did want strong
enforceable net neutrality their best
option would be to reclassify ISPs under
title 2 which allows for much stronger
oversight so the FCC did that and the
fact they did was huge
so when Verizon claims hey we love the
open Internet but why don't we just put
it on a different legal footing it's
basically a Jay Simpson asking why you
won't let him hold any of your samurai
swords come on juice you know why you of
anyone should know why
and the ISPs now have a powerful ally on
their side because Trump has appointed a
new head of the FCC and it is this guy a
jape I is known for being anti
regulation Pro merger last month he said
he wanted to quote take a weed whacker
to current FCC rules and predicted net
neutrality quote days are numbered Wow
okay days are numbered and take a weed
whacker or serial killer talk so that is
pretty ominous when the Code of Federal
Regulations looks out of its window at
night there's just a j't pie standing
silently holding his weed whacker
waiting for his chance but the dangerous
thing about pies that he presents
himself as a fun down-to-earth nerd the
kind of guy whose Twitter feed is full
of quotes from The Big Lebowski he
quotes it all the time and look grunting
the Big Lebowski is fine in certain
contexts for example if you're an actor
and it's 1998 and you're filming the
movie The Big Lebowski but it is
completely intolerable in any other
context and that's that's not his only
fun guy at the office traits just watch
his very first press conference as
chairman I would be happy to take care
questions from the panel mining telecom
daily how do you plan to examine
yes ad July is the kind of guy who has a
fun oversized novelty mug and he is
really proud of it his theory is showing
it off to a reporter here he is showing
it off to his Twitter feed and in his
first speech to his staff as
commissioner he said I love walking into
my office poring about a gallon of
coffee into my infamous Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup spark and starting my day and
you heard right he described his own mug
as infamous which is offensive for two
reasons first and no point should you be
describing your own fun mug allowed in
the company of other adults and second
it's a mug pouring of mug
infamous is like calling your neti pot a
real panty dropper
no context can that be remotely true but
for all the pies doofy hey I'm just like
you guys persona there is there are some
things about him that you should really
know he's a former lawyer for Verizon
and despite being a smart man he sure
loves to play dumb over why is PS were
ever moved to title 2 for decades before
2015 we had a free and open Internet
indeed the free and open Internet
developed and flourished under
light-touch regulation we weren't living
in some digital dystopia before the
partisan imposition of a massive plan
hatched in Washington saved all of us
now that is true 2015 was not a digital
dystopia for anyone with the possible
exception of Pizza rat because think
about it the internet put that rat
through hell one cheat day in three
months of eating paleo
and she never hears the end of
it oh that's right I can't see hashtag
creepy Pelt monster hashtag feminism but
but fine
why is larger argument there he's deeply
disingenuous because he has to know that
Verizon his ex-employer won a lawsuit
that meant if the FCC wanted strong
enforceable protection it's only real
option was to reclassify the ISPs and
yet he cheerily insists under
questioning there is just no evidence
the cable companies were engaging in
rampant wrongdoing but to say Comcast
created a new TV series it just so
happened that that competed with a
Netflix series very similarly if these
rules go away how is the house they're
not an incredible incentive for Comcast
to slow Netflix down coming into my
house and make their video the comcast
video very robust so under that
hypothetical one things that's important
to remember is that it is a hypothetical
that we don't see evidence of that
happening in the marketplace on a
widespread level but here's the thing
there are multiple examples of ISP
over the years frizzes a few
years back the Roizen AT&T and t-mobile
at one point shut out Google Wallet from
their thumbs a product that
coincidentally happened to compete with
their own mobile payment app
and out incidentally that had a
significant flaw it's a little subtle
but see if you can spot it following in
the footsteps of PayPal and Google
Wallet it's a virtual mobile wallet app
called Isis that is incredible
if only because it leaves it at some
point someone's mom probably sent a text
along the lines of how do I make a
payment to Isis you have long yes let me
know about Passover and I think you met
me when people complained that they
couldn't use Google Wallet t-mobile sent
out tweaks and this is true like we're
supporting Isis we're really loving Isis
and we have chosen to work with Isis and
how to roll that out to everyone very
soon and yet despite t-mobile's vocal
support for Isis which is all you should
ever think about now whenever you hear
the word t-mobile or Isis for that
matter they're essentially the same
thing pardis main argument is that we
don't need title two to have net
neutrality but some of these ideas for
what to have instead are almost
laughably lacks for instance he
reportedly floated just having ISPs
voluntarily agree not to obstruct or
slow consumer access to web content by
putting that promise in their toes of
service you know the things that no
human being has ever read and that can
change whenever companies want them to
that idea would basically make net
neutrality as binding as a proposal on
The Bachelor Vanessa I have determined
you to be marginally better for my brand
than Corinne but I reserve the right to
change these agreements in the future
should ABC ever offered me a slot on
pile island and entice other big
arguments to remove ISPs from title 2 if
their place is too great a regulatory
burden on companies and that it's
already caused them to scale back their
investment in broadband networks the
economics are simple here more heavily
you regulate something the less of it
you're going to get so what happened
after the FCC imposed title 2 sure
enough infrastructure investment
declines ok so what is essentially
suggesting there is that as soon as
title 2 came in come from
said it investing in infrastructure
is way too difficult now we're not doing
it anymore in fact pull some of the
cable out of the ground we're going back
to the Telegraph but but it is worth
noting infrastructure investment is
harder to measure than you may think
and PI's numbers are in disputed back
several companies have gone on the
record saying their business has largely
been unaffected by title 2 and maybe the
best way to gauge title twos impact is
to listen to what cable companies told
their own investors to whom they are
legally obligated to tell the truth so
here is what Verizon told its investors
in 2014 about what the switch to title 2
would mean for them I mean to be real
clear I mean this does not this does not
influence the way we invest I mean we're
going to continue invest in our networks
and our platforms both in wireless and
wireline FiOS and and where we need to
so so nothing will influence that ok so
that doesn't really sound like net
neutrality was jeopardizing investment
at all although to be fair that was a
phone call and it was the Rison so it's
entirely possible that every other word
was dropped the fact is the fact is
title 2 is the most solid legal
foundation we have right now for a
strong enforceable net neutrality
protections so pi saying let's have an
open Internet without it it's like me
saying hey how about you have a gallon
of coffee without your stupid
mug just pour it into your hands and
trust that you won't get burnt oh and
mr. Chairman I know that you're probably
thinking well you're only making fun of
my mug because you're jealous of it so I
would say why would I be jealous
you want to know what I'm drinking I'm
drinking the blood of smaller mums sale
[Music]
see I think will tell you that net
neutrality could be protected by an act
of Congress but I do not particularly
trust this or any Congress to get
something as complicated as this right
and I definitely wouldn't want the
current president involved as and this
will not surprise you he doesn't seem to
have any idea what any of this is Trump
wants tweeted back in 2014
Obama's attack on the Internet is
another top-down power grab net
neutrality is the Fairness Doctrine will
target conservative media but that's the
exact opposite of what it did Trump
could not have been more off-base if he
tweeted net neutrality is the Monroe
Doctrine will target the wu-tang clan so
sadly it seems once more We the People
must take this matter into our own hands
because the FCC are again going to
invite public comment on their website
and conveniently for them the process is
actually a lot more complicated this
time than it was three years ago you
have to go to FCC gov slash lower case
ecfs slash search - proceedings then
when you get to this page put in the
proceeding number which is 17 - 108 then
hit search and on the next page
restoring Internet freedom should be the
only result you see then click on the
link that says Express and then and only
then can you leave your comment and if
you think it will look that's just too
complicated I'm not doing it don't worry
because that's why we bought the URL go
FCC yourself calm and if you simply go
there it will allow you spread all the
pain where
titovs fret and comment telling a GFI
that you specifically support strong net
neutrality that's my title to oversight
of ISPs and every internet group needs
to come together like you successfully
did three years ago every subculture
must join as one gamers YouTube
celebrities Instagram models Tom from
MySpace if you're still alive we need
all of you even and I cannot believe I'm
saying this Donald Trump's internet fans
on sites like 4chan and reddit the most
powerful online trolls of all this
subject is one of the few things that we
actually really agree on so simply
express yourselves and harness the race
that you normally reserved for me the
race that you use when you said I'm
genuinely one of the most visually an
intellectual repulsive people I've ever
seen with oddly long thumbs batshit
crazy eyes and a mouth that looks like a
cemetery after an earthquake thumbs up
that's pretty good the point is everyone
needs to get involved comment now and
then maybe comment again once the FCC
makes this proposal official even call
your representative and your Senators
and do not tell me that you don't have
time to do this if the Internet is
evidence of nothing else it is evidence
that we all have way too much time on
our hands and yes I'm talking to you
everyone who posted may the 4th be with
you for Star Wars day this and every
gear and I'm talking to you if
you want to post it on Facebook about 10
concerts you've seen and one you didn't
and two you everyone who did it
ironically and added a clever joke twist
because and this is important you are
exactly as bad because you cannot say
you are too busy when five hundred and
forty thousand of you commented on
Beyonce's pregnancy announcement and 673
you took the time to review the Grand
Canyon on Yelp seven of whom gave it a
one-star review what the is wrong
with you
and I'm specifically looking at you
person on Amazon who gave the wolf of
wallstreet one star because and I quote
there were no wolves in the loser
and could you he's 31 people who took
the time to say they found that review
helpful and finally I'm looking at the
frankly surprising number of people who
for some reason keep tweeting choke me
daddy at the Pope you are you're wasting
your time he's not going to choke you
the objects would be very bad so come on
I'm calling upon all of you the Internet
time wasters join me once more into five
to ten minutes of nine effort I need you
to guzik once more unto the breach my
friends you are everything to deserve
that neutrality and title to once again
commenter America needs you to rise or
more accurately remain seated in front
of your computer screen to the occasion
so please fly my proteins to fly one
[Applause]